God bless you all democracy thank you
[Music]
thank you
oh how I missed that elderly man
pretending to be president hello
everyone I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben reported September 2nd 2022 and
I'm back in business baby uh hopefully
you got to see at least a portion of my
back on the grid show yesterday which we
shot at the brand spanking new local
studios here in Miami with my friend and
uh well we'll get to a little of this
later but sort of mentor Larry Elder he
brought me back and uh surprise surprise
not much great stuff happened the
endless slide into lunacy continued uh
but here I am we're back in business
we've got a new home set as you can see
we wanted something a little lighter and
brighter to convey the joy and Beacon of
Freedom that is Florida I think we're
digging it I hope you're digging it will
we'll check in the comments to see what
you think uh and oh by the way as long
as I mentioned the locals Studio we do
know the lighting was a little dark for
the first show we are going to fix that
make a couple other adjustments and it's
very cool actually because you know I
just had this idea a few years ago to
build something that would compete with
patreon that's what locals became we
merged with Rumble and now we've got
offices for not just for me Studios and
offices but for all sorts of other
creators that are on the platforms and
we really are building those alternative
pipes uh before I get to the to the meat
of what we're doing here today just want
to say uh thank you for uh sticking with
us while I was gone throughout August
you know we put up a bunch of Clips we
did all these pre-taped like here's some
banana stuff that happened so I'm just
catching up on a lot of the nonsense
that I missed but I really did not hear
anything in August about covid about
Biden about Ukraine about any of this
stuff uh mostly it was diapers and Butt
Paste as I said to Larry yesterday uh
Justin is here he is downstairs right
now we will see how the sound proofing
of this studio is if he starts crying
but uh but life is good and I really do
feel a sort of renewed desire or not
even desire I feel A Renewed push I
would say to uh to save the world and as
I often say I have nothing better to do
than save the world so that's what we're
going to keep doing around here uh and
Today's show is going to be a little bit
uh a little bit of a look back and uh
touching on some of the stuff that I
missed a lot of you were wondering why
we didn't cover the uh the big Sam
Harris brouhaha yesterday which I guess
happened a couple weeks ago Sam on a
podcast said some strange things but I
wanted a little time uh well actually I
didn't know about it obviously Phoenix
who was setting up our show for
yesterday intentionally left it out
because obviously Sam and I are or were
friends he didn't want me to just be
sprung on something with with uh you
know going live just like that without
having a little bit more context so I
was able to see some of the stuff today
so today we're going to kind of go over
where I've been where guys like Sam have
been where guys like Joe Rogan have been
what's really going on in the country
right now and then of course we got to
that uh that cold open that we did there
Joe Biden just gave another just
completely insane speech and yeah he
doesn't know what he's saying but I mean
the Optics of that thing were right out
of Germany like Circa 1938 like
absolutely awful and the speech was just
terrible and uh just well look he's
still president it was 50 50 honestly
when I left in July it was really 50 50
whether he'd still be president but he
is still pretending so we're gonna get
to all of that stuff oh and I have a new
jacket how about that thanks to Tony who
hooked me up and is probably watching
right now uh real quick guys let me talk
about bully and Max and then we'll get
to it you know as inflation surpasses
highs not seen in 40 years the value of
the dollar is decreasing with every
passing day you're paying more at the
pump the grocery store for cars and
housing face it paper money is worth
less friends the timing couldn't be any
better for my new sponsor bullion Max
bullion Max is a direct to Consumer
precious metals retailer who can help
you diversify into gold and silver it's
a hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
Crisis and here's why I love bully and
max they're owned by vets in the
precious metal space offer some of the
lowest prices on the internet and they
make it so easy to buy directly from
their website I want to help you get
started so I worked out a special offer
just for you get bullion Max's silver
starter kit as a kit at employee pricing
just go to booleanmax.com Dave the kit
includes five of the most desirable
silver products to invest in including
the silver American eagle and a silver
Australian kangaroo the offer is limited
to just one per household so get yours
now go to bullionmax.com Dave and now
back to me okay
so Larry Elder brings me back on the
grid I hear about this marlago raid
which sounds like just another extension
of the general Trump derangement lunacy
of this Administration and the entire
deep State and the FBI okay fine fine
fine hear about a few other things that
happened uh over the month but but sort
of in my estimation actually nothing
sort of crazy happened you know everyone
was saying to me yesterday oh you missed
so much crazy stuff it was like ah a lot
of it just felt like no just kind of the
continuation of the sort of slow descent
as I always describe it the slow descent
into ludacity that we're all in there
was a clip that apparently went viral
about two weeks ago this is Sam Harris
on the trigonometry podcast which I've
done the trigonometry podcast I consider
those guys friends there they're doing
some good stuff over there it's a
British podcast and they do a lot of
similar stuff that we do here anyway Sam
went on uh to defend censorship
and getting Trump off Twitter and why we
shouldn't care about Hunter Biden's
laptop and a whole bunch of other stuff
so this is Sam a couple weeks ago listen
I don't care what's in Hunter Biden's I
made a hunter Biden at that point Hunter
Biden literally could have had the
corpses of children in his basement I
would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
Hunter Biden right it's not it's like
it's not Joe Biden but even if Joe like
even whatever scope of Joe Biden's
corruption is like if you if we could
just go down that rabbit hole endlessly
and and understand that he's getting
kickbacks from Hunter and Biden's deals
in Ukraine or whatever else right or
China
it is
infinitesimal compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved in it's like
it's like it's like a firefly to the sun
right I mean like there's just it
doesn't even it doesn't even stack up
against Trump University right Trump
University as a story is worse than
anything that could be in in Hunter
Biden's laptop in my view right now
that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York posts Twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted right and I'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not Simon I'm sorry that particular
person I'm really sorry I was the one
that said we should move on but you've
just said something I really struggled
with that which is
the kids in the basement you no no [ __ ]
the kids in the basement I'm interested
in democracy you're saying you are
content
with a left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no I'm content well so
but the thing is it's just not left wing
right so Liz Cheney is not left wing
right Liz Cheney
to prevent somebody from being
Democratic no but there's nothing
conspiracy it's not it was a conspiracy
out in the open it does but it doesn't
matter if it doesn't matter what parts
conspiracy what parts out in the open
okay so there is a lot to unpack there
as Sam would say so first off I want to
just say something Sam and I were
friends for many years I'm not really
sure if we're friends anymore to be
quite honest with you and it doesn't
really matter and I'm not going to
attack him personally here I'm just
simply not going to do that uh seven
years ago this week in 2015 I think this
was on September 12 2015. we launched
the Reuben report uh as this show and uh
as an interview show at first and then
ultimately what became this Sam was my
first guest
um so he's been an integral part and I
would say my own political evolution as
many of you know and I wrote about it
don't burn this book you know Sam on
Real Time with Bill Maher when he got
into that fight with Ben Affleck as Sam
was calmly talking about the difference
between criticizing ideas in this case
he was talking about ideas about
religion versus being bigoted towards
people it was a major wake-up moment for
me it was a major wake up for for
millions and millions of other people
but our political paths have diverged
now I always always always go out of my
way to not let politics affect
friendship a lot of other people have
trouble with that I find generally
speaking liberals leftists whatever have
trouble separating politics and people I
find conservatives generally speaking
and certainly Libertarians
are willing to accept that oh people
have different feelings about you and oh
you might have voted this way and I
might have voted this way and you
believe abortion should be this and I
believe abortion should be that and this
is about the death penalty where
liberals generally speaking again seem
to have this thing that if you don't
fully agree with us um we kind of can't
be friends with you so Sam and his wife
have been to my house for dinner our
house to dinner for many many times uh
we've I've done events with him all
sorts of stuff
um about six or eight months ago I had
sent out a tweet saying to a bunch of my
liberal friends and I was talking about
Sam Harris and Barry Weiss and Jonathan
Hyde people have been on the show I said
hey you know maybe now you guys are
realizing that you were a little bit off
on Trump I'd love to continue that
conversation uh and Sam just unfollowed
me on Twitter so that's I don't mean to
make this about me except there is
something bigger here because what you
just saw right there Sam talking there
became a sort of culturally important
moment so let's as I as Sam would say
pack a little bit of what he said first
off in essence he's okay with censorship
if the censorship accomplishes what he
wants it to accomplish this is really
really dangerous because basically
anyone in power might want to censor
people so that they could stay in power
and if you're saying it's okay to get
what you want then anyone else can say
it's okay to get what they want also he
seems to be completely dismissive of
what happened with the hunter Biden
laptop and whether whether what was on
the laptop whether it had to do with
Hunter Biden's business dealings in
Ukraine China Etc and that the fact that
he was obviously hired
to do things that he was not qualified
for because it was the access to the to
the vice president at the time now the
President Joe Biden
um there's all sorts of things on that
laptop whether they were pictures of him
smoking cracker with the prostitutes or
whether it was deep business related
stuff and emails that you could then
blackmail Joe Biden for it so to
completely dismiss it as if it doesn't
matter or that Trump has just
automatically done something worse is
really bizarre I mean and this is what
Trump derangement syndrome is it takes
relatively clear thinking people and it
makes everything that happens in the
world can be excused because Donald
Trump is worse so you can actually do
anything you can say I'm for free speech
and I'm against censorship but you can
censor if it's going to stop evil Donald
Trump uh and then he talks about Trump
University I'm not going to defend Trump
University I don't really care about
Trump University Trump had Trump vodka
that failed Trump had casinos that
failed all sorts of he's a businessman
who does things that sometimes succeed
and sometimes fail I'm not even
pretending that he's the most moral
person in the world or doesn't do some
corrupt things or he's a New York City
Builder you've got to do some freaking
corrupt things obviously and also he's a
politician now and politicians whether
they are Republicans Or democrats or
anything else have to do uh corrupt
things dishonest things all of that but
the the broader point is is the idea of
censoring when you think it's okay and
and that is really really dangerous so I
can see clearly why two weeks ago or so
that really caught the internet on fire
because Sam was thought of I think in
many ways he's in that sort of Bill
Maher group of as like sort of one of
these like last liberals who's not
completely insane I would say he's one
of the people that I would like to kind
of move a little bit and go hey you know
if you're against the woke stuff and the
gender stuff and you know all that well
then you gotta kind of come around and
realize what time it is right
um but okay he hasn't quite got there he
did did then after some of the brouhaha
he did do on his podcast I guess a bit
of a clarification of his remarks
although I think it sort of just dug the
thing even deeper I've said on several
occasions that I think Donald Trump is a
worse person than Osama bin Laden the
statement is obviously meant to get your
attention
I get that it's surprising
but it's not meant to be hyperbolic
I can defend every word of a statement
like that what I can't defend are
people's misunderstandings and erroneous
extrapolations of a statement like that
okay so look I I don't know that people
from what I've seen or the way I'm
analyzing it right now are
misunderstanding uh what he said
um I also find generally like listening
to podcasters who talk in that slow NPR
voice it's very very hard to listen to
uh anyway I think this is all
interesting again not to attack Sam I
think he's mistaken on this thing
whether we ever break bread again or not
is actually irrelevant but I think he's
sort of this is what's happening it's
sort of similar to the Jon Stewart video
that went viral a couple weeks ago these
sort of half non-woke Liberals are
realizing that none of their policies
work none of it makes sense and that and
that all you have is to fight against
this this imaginary Trump thing because
it's not even the real Trump thing right
like Trump things were a lot better when
Trump was President it's very simple uh
it's very obvious like we all we all can
kind of see that so what I wanted to do
here was show you a little bit of how
seven years ago this very week in 2015
Sam was my first guest and then you guys
know the story when it comes to me right
I decided to start really seeing where
the truth was seeing what was honest
about public policy that I had been
wrong about some things and a bunch more
and then shortly uh right after that I
did that why I left the left video
something that perhaps Sam should take a
look at
Free Speech do you believe that people
should be judged by their character not
their skin color
do you believe in freedom of religion
if you believe these things you're
probably not a progressive you might
think you're a progressive I used to
think I was my show the Reuben report
was originally part of the progressive
Young Turks Network
Progressive struck me as liberals but
louder progressives were the nice guys
they looked out for the little guy they
cared about women and minorities they
embraced change
in short who wouldn't want to be a
progressive I'm a classical liberal a
free thinker and as much as I don't like
to admit it defending my liberal values
has suddenly become a conservative
position so if you think people should
be able to say what they think without
being punished for it that people should
be judged by their behavior not their
skin color and that people should be
able to live the way that they want to
live without government interference
then there's not much left on the left
for you
okay so I think actually Sam does
understand a lot of the concepts there
obviously I think he's a little confused
as to whether he thinks people should be
able to say what they want to say
because he did uh applaud when Jack
Dorsey on Twitter booted Donald Trump
will get to more on that in just a
second but the reason I thought this was
all interesting for my first show back
is because as I said seven years ago
there we were sitting I was having a
wake up he was sort of in the in the
center of the thing and then and then
there was that whole intellectual dark
web thing that blew up that many of you
were following and there was me and
Peterson and Joe Rogan and Sam Harris
obviously at Majid Nawaz and a whole
bunch of other people but it's it's sort
of crumbled I don't even know what it
was it wasn't we didn't have laminated
cards we didn't have a secret hideout or
uh anything like that but there was this
group of people that were trying to
bring some level of sanity I think to
political discourse and now we've seen
you know some level of sanity in
political discourse completely developed
but some of us I think have started to
go what to wear reality is that we
didn't say oh we will only Define
Reality by what Donald Trump does and
that he is this you know this orange
Hitler and we must make all our
decisions based on what he does or does
not do I would say Jordan Peterson has
done a a great job of that an absolutely
great job of that you may remember this
tweet from Jordan back in March of 22.
he said I wasn't a conservative until
liberals kowtowed to the radicals now
this is a great Point by Jordan that
there are virtually no liberals left
there are a couple liberals who are
voting for the people who bring in the
bad stuff and they don't get there so so
the question I guess I would pose to Sam
uh is why do you consider yourself a
liberal anymore or is is defending Free
Speech not a liberal policy position
that you hold to anymore now what's also
interesting about this there was another
clip that went viral last week that I'm
just catching up on uh Aaron Rodgers
quarterback uh in the NFL for the
Packers uh he went on Joe Rogan's
podcast and they started talking
politics and Aaron Rodgers has been very
outspoken against covid vaccines and a
whole bunch more and Rogan seems to be
getting to the end of the road no one
who is alive today had ever experienced
a true pandemic
and I'm hoping that now that this is
over people are going to you know
recognize that some serious errors were
made and not repeat those that's the
best you can get out of it so what do
you tell those people vote Republican
that's what a lot of them are going to
do anyway yeah
congrats Joe can we send Joe like some
flowers or chocolate he seems like a
flowers and chocolate guy like he's
getting there he has already said that
he's he would vote for DeSantis if
DeSantis was to run for president now I
don't know that DeSantis is going to but
I suspect the Trump that Rogan would
support Trump this time if if that is
how it goes or he probably will support
whoever the Republican is but Joe you
have to remember this is a guy who four
years ago was a Bernie Sanders supporter
so now there's the road and you're
starting to realize that some of your
stuff is wrong and it doesn't make sense
and if you're Joe Rogan you're a Bernie
Sanders guy right so now you're for high
taxes you're for all these government
programs and if just these people had
the power they could do more properly
and all that stuff it's it's just a sort
of immature way of thinking okay fine
you're watching this show you've
probably evolved out of it yourself but
what does Joe Rogan do in the midst of
the pandemic and when he signs this
crazy what is probably like a 300
million dollar deal all in with Spotify
he gets out of California because he
realizes he's about to give California
30 million dollars roughly in state
income tax so the rubber met the road
with Joe Rogan he left California and he
went to Texas and now in the roughly
year and a half or so that he's been in
Texas he is now talking about voting for
Ron DeSantis to be president of the
United States He is telling people to
vote for Republicans this is not a
traditional Republican or conservative I
am fairly certain that was the smoke of
marijuana that was coming up during that
interview there he smokes weed he does
Ayahuasca he eats mushrooms he's into
the MMA stuff this is not the typical
stodgy old school conservative that we
think of but that's been the new
alignment that I have been trying to
show you guys for a long time so whether
Joe Rogan and I agree on everything or
disagree on everything or whatever or
whether he is exactly where I'm at or
not
um I think it's reflective of a lot of
Americans who are realizing that the big
Tech stuff the censorship stuff the
Trump derangement stuff the obsession
the January 6th hearings this has all
been endless nonsense the Mar-A-Lago
stuff it's all endless nonsense and we
have to do better it doesn't mean
Republicans are great but they're a
little bit better than the Democrats uh
so why are a whole bunch of us sort of
now on the scary right well we'll get to
that in just one second but you might
want to put on your relief band for that
segment because I'm going to be showing
you Joe Biden and as you know Joe Biden
and the Democrats they are making policy
decisions that are making us all
nauseous did you know that one out of
three Americans regularly suffer from
nausea but there's a solution you've got
to check out relief band relief band is
the number one FDA cleared anti-nausea
span that's been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more it's like the name says
it's legitimately a band you wear on
your wrist to relieve you from nausea
and anxiety and you change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker it's that simple
plus the product is 100 drug free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed and they
just released their newest model the
relief band sport so if you're finally
taking that summer trip or just nauseous
from everything going on in the world
I've got good news you can join over a
hundred thousand relief band users with
an exclusive offer just for my listeners
go to reliefband.com use promo code
Reuben and you'll receive 20 off plus
free shipping and a no questions asked
30-day money-back guarantees so head on
over to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Reuben get 20 off plus free shipping and
now back to me okay so let's let's
continue a little bit more with what
we're doing here on this first show back
on the grid that's a summation of my
life's work in many ways so why is it
that a guy like Joe Rogan is getting to
the end of the road and telling people
to vote for Republican even though if
you were to just check all the boxes
this guy is not a generic Republican and
Joe Rogan whether you think he's a silly
MMA guy or not or whether you like weed
or psychedelics or not he has hundreds
of millions of people that listen to him
every month he is by far the most
influential public figure in America
right now by far it's not even close in
terms of the amount of content he puts
out in the amount of people who are
listening to his thoughts and he's now
again going from in essence supporting
the Socialist to now realizing that you
have to defend Freedom so why is this
happening to him well it's not just that
I think he's having a wake up and
realizing hey I don't like paying those
taxes and they're the ones that locked
us down and a whole bunch more it's also
that the Democrats rhetoric and Biden
Joe Biden specifically the rhetoric has
gone completely insane so Joe Biden gave
this speech last night and if you have
not seen any of the video the image of
images of this it's dystopian it's right
out of Star Wars Palpatine it's right
out of Germany
1937. uh the the Optics of this thing
are absolutely horrible Biden again he's
just reading he doesn't know what he's
saying he can't regulate his emotions
all of that stuff well we got two clips
for you here and and just watch the
juxtaposition of what Biden does here
first
um we should be United I believe America
is at an inflection point
one of those moments
that determine the shape of everything
that's to come after
and now America must choose
to move forward
or to move backwards
to build a future or obsess about the
past
to be a nation of Hope and unity and
optimism
or a nation of fear
Division and of Darkness
all right so he seems kind of angry
while he's telling us about unity and
all that good you know flowery stuff
then moments later uh he did this
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
so it's just so extraordinary what he
does and again it's not coming from him
so it's whoever the speechwriter is and
it's whoever the entire whoever's entire
in charge of the entire event we're
going to make him look evil we're going
to have the two soldiers behind him and
the red and it all just looked nazi-ish
and evil and it's by Design guys it
really is by Design no it's by Design I
get these people are incompetent but
they're not that incompetent they know
what they're doing so in this speech
first he's telling us about Hope and we
have to be less divisive and we have to
look forward not backward okay always
twirling twirling that's a Simpsons
reference for some of you
um then a minute later Donald Trump and
the Maga Republicans you know basically
saying that they're terrorists and it's
like uh you do know that's about 74
million people by your math on the
election right that's 74 million people
you're saying are in essence evil
um I don't think that's going to go that
well with those 74 million people and
these aren't Stakes this is by design
that is in a speech by Design to
purposely confuse and conflate everybody
and sort of make it sound like he wants
Unity while he's also throwing half the
country under the bus and this is not
the first time that he's done this this
I think was from about a week ago again
I'm getting caught up on all of this
stuff uh when uh he defended himself
after calling Maga Republicans
semi-fascists what do you mean by
semi-fascism
[Music]
Senator Lindsey Graham said last night
there would be riots in the street if
former president Trump is prosecuted for
taking classified government documents
to Mar-A-Lago what is the White House
response to that so
um
we have you know we have seen Mega
Republicans attack our democracy we have
seen Mega Republicans take away our
rights uh make threats of violence uh
including this weekend and that is uh
what the president was referring to uh
when you all asked me uh last week about
the semi-fascism comment
so if I can link this back to a little
bit of where we started with Sam Harris
stuff the point here is is that sort of
like Sam Harris they're now saying the
quiet part out loud they are okay uh
silencing people whether it's through
big Tech or whatever means they see fit
they are okay using the FBI to
investigate the former president or
whether they want to hire I'm told 87
000 new IRS agents to look into your
finances so that the government can take
more of your money armed agents by the
way they're saying all the quiet things
out loud they call you fascist they call
Donald Trump fascist the idea that he
would use the power of the state and and
corporations to crack down on people
while they're the ones who are doing it
they were the ones who used the levers
of the state to influence corporations
during covid to fire the very people who
earlier were deemed the essential
workers firing nurses who who wanted to
my body my choice everything everything
they say is a lie you and you when you
know it it frees you it absolutely frees
you uh so we just showed I hadn't seen
her in about a month that was uh black
lesbian press secretary Corinne
Jean-Pierre and then she said something
even more insane uh this is just from
yesterday I mean this one is really
really wild and and well I'm not going
to tee up any further than to say does
this sound like uh true freedom to you
or mob rule again we see majority of
Americans who disagree and so when you
are not with where majority of Americans
are then you know that is Extreme that
is an extreme way of thinking
I mean if she believes that she there's
so much history that this woman needs to
learn but that that is what these people
think if most people believe something
is right and true then it must be right
and true and if you do not you are the
radical you are the extremist I mean
that is Mob rule on steroids that is how
all of the awful movements of history
that is how pogroms and holocausts and
all sorts of horrible things happen a
majority starts getting Drunk on Power
starts following a bad leader and then
is willing to do all sorts of bad things
to the minority the I you know you could
have a group of 20 people and just
because 19 people say that two plus two
equals five it doesn't mean that the one
guy who says two plus two is four is the
extremist I mean this is just absolutely
extraordinary but again it fits doesn't
this all sort of fit like a puzzle into
everything that's been going on here for
quite some time time so so what does
this all kind of lead us to because now
we are in the fall it is September and
that means we are basically two months
away from these midterm elections and
yes it does at least at the moment look
like there's going to be this massive
Red Wave and that's partly why Biden
is using the scary imagery and this Maga
Republican it's partly why he's doing
that because they all they've got is
they need people to be fearful whether
it's fearful of the the Maga extremists
or whether it's fearful of covid or
monkey pox or something else all they
have left
is that you will need us because you
will be afraid okay we're also about
nine months away from the Republican
primary season now so a bunch of
Republicans are going to get in on the
the presidential stage and we'll see how
that thing fights out and I hope that
it's a robust fight uh but again all of
this leads to that we have the we have a
really bizarre two months in front of us
right now because the Biden
Administration clearly is out of control
IRS agents everywhere going to
investigate Trump at Mar-A-Lago uh all
half the country are terrorists and an
election on the horizon so what do we do
about that because you know I like to
give you Solutions uh real quick let me
talk to you guys about real estate
agents I trust uh you guys know that
buying or selling a home is already one
of the most stressful things you can do
just like Joe Rogan who left his home in
California and moved to Texas and it can
be 10 times worse if you're not working
with the right agent generally speaking
our homes are our biggest investment
which of course is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their teams make the introduction
and then follow you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied they work with agents
with long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go to Real Estate agentsitrust.com
today give them some basic info they'll
contact you and you will move to Texas
or Florida or Tennessee and you will be
happy okay so what's next with all of
this stuff
should you and the people around you
uh
view Trump as the scariest thing the
Maga Republicans should you use the
power of big Tech to silence people that
you don't like should you listen to
people who have consistently gotten
things wrong and and I would basically
say Sam Harris at a political level has
pretty much gotten everything wrong if
you keep voting for Democrats and keep
saying that the very people who are
defending the freedoms you purport to
care about uh are the devil well then
you're getting stuff wrong so I think
that there's a couple things you can do
here I'd say three things you can go
down the path
and I suspect if you're watching this
you've either gone down the path maybe
you did it before maybe you did it with
me maybe you're on that path right now
but you know some people who are
figuring this stuff out right now so
they have three options I think or it's
or I'd say it's a three-pronged process
you can go down the path that that I've
gone down that Rogan seems to be going
down that Jordan that Jordan Peterson
has gone down and many people before us
went down Ronald Reagan went down that
path former Democrat okay many people
have done that then you have to ditch
the Sam Harris types I don't mean that
as an attack on him personally okay what
I mean that is that you have to say
goodbye to the people who keep making
the same mistakes over and over with
politics you maybe just have they just
have to have a little less influence
over your political thinking he does his
mindful meditation thing if that's given
you inner peace then spectacular uh and
then third I would say you have to pers
uh persuade
say the bill Mars or even the Joe
Rogan's even more we have to be more
forward in what we are doing we have to
be more confident in the arguments that
we're making and we have to be willing
to get into that fight when they will
have that fight with us now often they
don't want to have that fight because
we're a bunch of mean Nazis but we have
to be able to defend what we believe and
and build better things so look when uh
when Sam Harris to now bring us back to
where we started uh when When Donald
Trump was kicked off of Twitter Sam
Harris sent out uh this tweet I think we
have the Tweet he said there's an
important debate to have about the
wisdom of kicking Trump off Twitter I
still believe that it should have
happened years ago and that we've paid a
terrible price for the delay but for the
moment all I want to say is thanks Jack
so look the point is when I say people
that have got things wrong all along Sam
has been for censorship
and again I don't mean this to be a dick
and Sam if you're watching this video
I've enjoyed the many times that you and
your wife have come to our house for
dinner
um I'm not the one that that unfollowed
you on Twitter well I did after you
unfollowed me so I don't need to make
this like a personal bickering nonsense
but I'm trying to say is there's a track
record here of him being for censorship
even Jack Dorsey now has sort of now
that he's not in charge of Twitter
anymore has sort of backtracked and sort
of been like maybe we shouldn't have
gotten rid of trump and everyone knows
you know one of Sam's main lines over
the years has been sunlight is the best
disinfectant that you wanna allow people
to say things so that you can see it so
that you can counter it but he's been
getting this stuff wrong for quite some
time I actually responded to that tweet
and I don't think I was being a dick
actually a little glib perhaps I said
don't worry Sam I'll still stand up for
you when they take you out just kidding
I'll be taken out first but I'm sure
someone will be around and of course
that's always what it is right if you
don't stand up when people whether you
think they are justly or unjustly or
being censored and canceled and
disappeared and unpersoned well then
eventually they will come for you and
it's why one of the reasons I said one
of the few I think sort of mistakes that
I made over the last couple years was
that when they booted Alex Jones from
everything
whether I literally I kid you not I have
never watched even five cumulative
minutes of Alex Jones
um I've seen a lot of the screaming
videos and some of the silly stuff and
some of the obnoxious stuff and whatever
but I think perhaps I should have
offered more of a defense because of
course it was not going to stop with him
so then what we also have to do of
course is not is say we have to sort of
say goodbye to a certain set of people
that are just kind of getting the things
wrong but then for the people that are
really getting there and Rogan seems to
have gotten there basically and for Mar
who's on the way and I'm doing Bill
Marshall I'm going to LA on uh September
21st September 21st and I'm doing his
podcast two hours hopefully unedited and
we'll get to talk about as much of this
as he wants to talk about we got to keep
pushing them uh and speaking of pushing
them Larry Elder who brought me back on
the grid yesterday he referenced uh an
interview that he did with Bill Maher on
his show in 2013. this is Larry Elder's
radio show about nine years ago when he
got into it a little bit with Bill Maher
over what is a Libertarian and can Bill
call himself a Libertarian and they have
a somewhat respectful it gets a little
tense but somewhat respectful
conversation about it and this is what I
mean about defending what you believe
saying it honestly and clearly here's
Larry Elder and Bill Maher nine years
ago I have a request and I mean it bill
with all due sincerity you and I have
seen each other around town a little bit
I've always liked you personally
um please tell me why you can why you
insist on calling yourself a libertarian
when you are in favor of affirmative
action you are in favor of gun control
you've constantly railed against Ronald
Reagan and George Bush for tax cuts
against the rich you oppose Airline
deregulation you oppose poverty
regulation and for crying out loud you
voted for Ralph Nader and most
Libertarians I know would sooner vote
for Rasputin than Ralph Nader please
stop calling yourself a Libertarian you
know it's always amused me Larry that
every other political party is allowed
to have a big tent but the Libertarians
who you can't even Define most people
wouldn't even on the street tell you
what the word means we all have to march
in lockstep behind Larry Elder certain
things are not negotiable if you support
minimum wage you support affirmative
action these are not negotiable there's
a Libertarian party platform you can go
online and read at libertarianparty.org
Republican Party platform that plenty of
people vote Republican and don't believe
half of it that's what politics is in
America there are core values that you
have to have as a Libertarian and one of
them is adherence to to article one
section 8 of The Constitution and the
things that you want especially gun
control affirmative action are
absolutely inconsistent with that you
are not a Libertarian Bill you're a
progressive or a liberal I don't know
what you are but you're not a
libertarian okay so it gets a little
heated there at the end and so be it but
the reason I wanted to show you that is
because nine years ago Larry Elder was
trying to sort of show Bill Maher hey
you know in essence he's saying hey you
don't seem to love the government right
because you want to smoke weed you want
to live life however you want to live it
you want to say whatever you want to say
and not fear the government is going to
come get you and all of those things
um and so why do you call yourself a
Libertarian now Bill actually makes a
good point that you should have big
tents across the board that I believe
right like what am I what am I trying to
do right now what have I been trying to
do for the last two years at this point
it's that I believe that the Republicans
can be a really big wide tent that are
going to have more of the social
libertarian say people like me and then
can you fit that with the religious
conservatives this is this is tough
stuff that has to get worked out okay so
Bill to that extent I think he's right
like you can you can have libertarian
beliefs and does that fit within a
Libertarian party okay there's something
to be said there but then Larry counters
that with well wait a minute just in
essence what he's saying is hey well
just because you want to smoke weed you
can't be for high taxes you can't be for
a lot of the other big government stuff
that you seemingly are for and against
the people who come in and and fix a lot
of that stuff but the reason I showed
you that clip because is because Larry
who brought me back on yesterday Larry
had an awful lot to do with my Awakening
which you know about so that video that
we showed you earlier of why I left the
left that's been seen uh Phoenix just
told me 30 million times on the prageru
website 30 million times so it's
probably been seen many more times than
that so that's a lot of people who are
seeing something and hopefully start
going on their Adventure well this uh
we're just going to show you a portion
of my first interview with Larry Elder
many of you have seen at times time and
time again and many of you have told me
in real life this is the thing that woke
you up to this was Larry defending what
he believes saying what he believes
calmly factually uh and decently and
guess what it got me going down that
road that Rogan seems to be going down
right now that Bill Maher is
begrudgingly going going down a little
bit and that I think Sam Harris
unfortunately doesn't seem to be getting
to but take a look you wouldn't not
acknowledge that there are some systemic
issues give me an example tell me what
you think the most systemic racist issue
is what is it well I would say that
because black people in most cases in
many cases were descendants of slaves
that racism as a as an institution that
it's just two thousand a certain amount
of it just exists 2015. give me the most
blatant racist example you can come up
with right now
um I think you could probably find
evidence that in general cops are that
cops are more willing to shoot if the uh
perpetrator is black what's your data
then why what's your basis for saying
that last year well look I know a lot of
people would say look what's going on I
know what they would say I'm talking
about what the facts are 965 people were
shot by cops last last year and killed
four percent of them were white cops
shooting unarmed blacks in in Chicago in
2011 21 people were shot and killed by
cops in 2015 there were seven uh in
Chicago which is a third black a third
white and a third Hispanic seventy
percent of the homicides are black on
black uh about 40 per month almost 500
uh in the per year last year in Chicago
and 75 of them are unsolved where is the
black lives matter on that the idea that
a racist white cop uh and shooting
unarmed black people is apparel to black
people is BS it's complete and total BS
so if you know what you're talking about
and you say it plainly and clearly and
then you've got somebody on the other
side who maybe is willing to listen and
I guess that was me at that point that
was about six years ago you might really
get there with people and that is at
least partly how we'll fix this country
at the political level but there are
some other ways we can fix this country
and uh since I already played in my
first prageru video from about seven
years ago here's my last one from just a
few months ago are we just gonna give up
on the greatest country in the history
of the world or are we going to fight
for freedom and a thriving future
they always tell us that we're at a once
in a lifetime pivotal moment but this
time they're actually right you know it
I know it you know that I know it I know
that you know it and they know we all
know it so what are we going to do about
it well I've got a few ideas
first off be an individualist the
American Heritage dictionary defines an
individualist as one that asserts
individuality by independence of thought
and action the left demands that you be
part of the collective a hive mind where
everyone thinks the same anyone outside
the hive mind must be shouted down
harassed or canceled
is that the world you want to be part of
how about this instead be an
individualist be a member of a family be
part of a community you know what that
sounds like to me
America
dare I say I'm following my own advice
be an individualist well you got that
part with me uh be a member of a family
I just extended my family and be part of
a community we just open up some offices
right here in Miami and we're supporting
local businesses uh so look guys I think
the theme of this comeback show has been
there is a path you can see it hopefully
you're on it and hopefully you can get
other people to join you on the
adventure and then we can all get to the
promised land together and the
ridiculous speeches by Joe Biden or the
confused ideas of censorship uh by Sam
Harris they'll all sort of be things in
the past and we will have the widest
tent of Freedom loving Americans that
this country has ever seen I honestly
believe that we can get there maybe
that's a little bit of the endorphins of
being off the grid for a month or it's
just freaking reality I actually think
it's maybe a little bit of both uh all
right we can't do any locals questions
today because I got to get to the local
to the local studio right now because
I'm interviewing
um who am I where I'm interviewing Jared
Kushner man it's been crazy coming back
uh so we're doing that live uh in about
an hour so I do got a bolt right now uh
but stick around for a cold close and
we'll get to questions and everything
else uh when we get back next week and
uh it's just good to be back everybody
so I hope you're doing well hope you had
a great summer and uh here's a little a
little outro cold close for you I would
I would get much more engaged in the
world we can't step back
for example we solved the problem in the
United States America and you don't
solve in other parts of the world you
know what's going to happen we're going
to have you're gonna have travel bans
you're gonna not be able to do have have
economic intercourse around the world
there's a lot look when America goes
alone when America is first it's America
alone